[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten wild heute mache ich auch mal
wieder eine leckeren klassiker und zwar
ist es so der klassiker aus unserer
familie es gibt nämlich zitronenkuchen
und dieses rezept habe ich von meiner
schwester schon vorüber ist vorüber war
jetzt nämlich 26
ich glaube mit neun oder zehn habe ich
den das erste packen also schon vor über
15 jahren habe ich das bekommen und das
rezept wurde auch nie verändert und mit
immer so weiter gemacht deswegen gebe
ich euch das heute weiter es ist auch
immer schneller kuchen vereinfacher
kuchen also im prinzip kann nicht jeder
nachmachen
vor allem sind es zutaten die hat x fach
stehen wir zu hause zumindest ich und
deswegen ist es ein kuchen der man immer
machen kann wenn man einfach mal
sonntags nichts zu tun hat und tristan
leckere kuchen
ich zeige euch mal die zutaten für den
rührteig ich habe hier 250 gramm butter
dies bereits zimmer waren die habe ich
gestern abend schon aus dem kühlschrank
herausgestellt dann habe ich hier 250
gramm zucker
ich benutze etwas vanille extrakte ihr
könnt auch gern vanillezucker nehmen
aber wissenschaft intensiver dann habe
ich hier sechs eier die sind auch zimmer
waren hier habe ich eine bio zitrone
davon braucht saft und schale und für
das zitronenaroma nämlich sogar noch ein
bisschen zitronenaroma das sage ich
gleich noch was dazu dann habe ich hier
300 gramm mehl 100 gramm speisestärke
und ein päckchen backpulver also macht
es in echt ganz wenige zutaten und so
richtig standard zutaten aus dem
vorratsschrank jetzt kommt die butter in
die rührschüssel und früher habe ich
keine küchenmaschine da ging das ganz
einfach im handrücken rät muß man hat
einfach diese länger rühren
da gebe ich jetzt den zucker mit rhein
und ruhr jetzt
von unten nach oben also von stufe 2 bis
10 gleich nämlich bis 10 bis 8 gleich
hoch und lass es so etwa drei bis fünf
minuten krieg werden so dass sich an der
zugang bisschen auflöst
[Musik]
und jetzt gebe ich dir nach und nach die
eier mit dazu und lass es einfach nur
schön geschmeidig verrühren
also immer kurz warten bis das eine ein
untergerührt ich und dann das nächste
mit dazu
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich mir die zitrone und
reift da die schale rein und kam dann im
anschluss gleich den saft auspressen und
ich habe jetzt hier wollen dieses
zitronenaroma angesprochen und zwei
schuss von der gleichen firma wiemann
vanille extrakt und ich bin da krasse am
ausprobieren welche aromen ich noch
nicht aufnehmen möchte
wichtig ist mir dabei nur dass das hat
alles natürliche aromen sind und zitrone
auch immer recht auf jeden fall
vermeiden bei coop und ich hoffe das
kommt bei einem kuchen richtig gut raus
[Musik]
eine saftpresse ich gleich noch aus
hierfür rühre ich jetzt kurz backpulver
mit dem mähen damit das backpulver es
nicht so kommt einfach kurz vermischen 7
brauche ich meine möglich weil das
dieses extra fein de mail ist wobei es
ein ganz normales 405 melisch das hat
nur das von der globus marke und schon
immer so schön fein und dann gebe ich
das hier mit rein
auch die stärke
und jetzt gebe ich noch mal milde aroma
mit dazu ein paar tropfen und probiert
auch das betonen aroma
ein bisschen luft reichen und jetzt 30
noch die zitrone aus und verliert das
ganze und falls sie ihr merkt ihr
braucht auch noch flüssigkeit kann da
gerne noch ein schluck milch mit dazu
geben oder noch ein bisserl zitronensaft
aber ansonsten kann das einfach so
lassen
[Musik]
und jetzt ganz wichtig bei mittlerer
stufe 1 verrühren bzw kleiner stufe und
ich spritze nämlich gleich alles raus
jetzt kann ich den teig in meine
backform einführen ich habe zweimal den
bug haben so auf größte stufe
eingestellt
ihr könnt aber zum beispiel auch ganz
einfach ein backblech benutzen also habe
ich das früher auch gemacht geht beides
[Musik]
und dann einfach kurz bestreichen und
der vorteil von seinem bug rahmen ist
einfach ich habe unten los und dünnes
blech mit löchern drin und dann wachst
es eben schneller und ich hab halt hier
außen immer so rechte winkel und kann
später eben schöner schneiden und im
backfield zufahrt zu 23 minuten länger
backen
aber wie gesagt habe ich früher auch
gemacht
[Musik]
und so wie der teig im vorgeheizten
backofen bei ober und unterhitze so
ungefähr bei 180 grad für ungefähr 25
bis 30 minuten gebacken
sie hat auf jeden fall mit zahnstocher
sich stäbchen probe machen und wenn
nichts mehr dran hängt nämlich ihn raus
und lassen einfach komplett abkühlen
[Musik]
mein zitronenkuchen sitz abgekühlt und
jetzt kann ich den rahmen entfernen
mache ich jetzt mal kurz mit einer
palette weil ich meine leistung bringen
dann hast du meinen stocken bringen
messer besser
o
und es riecht auch schon richtig lecker
zitronig als ich glaube diese zitrone
bis mich echt mit auf jetzt kann ich das
hier raus nehmen und auch mein torten
retter setzen bzw 70 es noch mal um und
ziehe den kuchen komplett von der bak
unterlage weg weil ich das gleiche noch
schneiden will und auf der bank machte
darf man schneiden beschuldigte kaputt
[Musik]
und jetzt kann ich hier noch den bus
vorbereiten und zwar habe ich dazu nur
zwei brauche ich dafür nutzt zutaten zu
einer gramm puderzucker und eine zitrone
dass ich jetzt wieder eine bio zitrone
wenig benutzte auch ein bisschen was von
der schale das noch zitronige haben und
ich nehme mir vorher so ein bisschen was
von der orangenschale zitronenschale weg
so ist nämlich nicht gleich für die deko
[Musik]
ich hatte ein paar zitronen 5 und das
regt zur code zitronenschale müssten auf
jeden fall
[Musik]
das reicht schon denn das weiß der ihnen
dann möchte ich jetzt nicht nehmen jetzt
nötig die zitrone ganz kurz durch kommt
nämlich ein bisschen saft raus und
brauchen messer
und jetzt kommt hier einfach
zitronensaft rein
zuerst nehme ich mal nur die hälfte und
wenn ich merke ich brauch noch ein
bisschen nämlich noch die andere hälfte
nicht einfach verrühren und man merkt
dann mit dem rühren dass der große jetzt
noch ein bisschen zu fest ist also
brauche ich noch die zweite zitronen
hälfte kommt dann immer darauf an wie
groß die sind erst mal weniger
das dürfte zum 30 und diesen
zitronenkuchen kann man zum beispiel im
winter auch ganz gut abwandeln ihren
orangen kuchen dann nehme ich nämlich
einfach statt zitronen orangen jetzt
gebe ich den bus auf meinen kuchen drauf
ich sehe auch gleich jetzt nicht ganz
flüssig aber auch nicht so fest als er
läuft schön vom löffel runter und so
sollte die konsistenz und einer palette
kann man das ist schön wert für streit
und auch schnell verstreichen
[Musik]
jetzt nämlich einfach die euren zitronen
testen und gibt die noch so ein bisschen
gekauft
[Musik]
als elfter einfach so oder halt direkt
auf die stückchen ich mach das dazu und
dann schneiden wir gleich das stückchen
[Musik]
mein kurs jetzt kommt also der cousins
komplett fest geworden und ich zeige
euch mal wie es aussieht wenn man es
nicht abwarten kann oder den kuchen
forschung schneidet und zwar hier da
habe ich vorhin vergessen den kuchen
feststellen zu lassen und deshalb geht
es dem ist er halt so halbe stunde
warten bis er abgekühlt und fest
geworden ist und dann kann man ihnen
nämlich ganz knapp durch schneiden oder
murat wartet jetzt auch schon ganz
ungeduldig auf sein stück ich war bereit
es gab schon lang einen zitronenkuchen
mal waren hier früher habe ich dann
glaube ich jeder hoch machst du halt so
da kochen schlechthin hat man hier die
schöne stückchen weg
wie nennt sich der mutterkuchen einer
nonne wieder eingefangen kuchen gesagt
während sich der mutterkuchen einer
nonne christstollen heißt zu weihnachten
bringen
ja stimmt ich nur so ein gefühl hat ein
stückchen darf probieren
ich bin auf diese reden geschwungen
er hat ein richtig toller weg zurück
also ja wo ist richtig gut haben oder
kaffee auf die schnelle ganz genau der
perfekte kuchen ein super einfacher
klassiker und wenn jedes rezept jetzt
auch nach machen wollt dann schaut
einfach auf meinem blog vorbei aufs eis
- blog.de da gibt es nämlich alle
zutaten und die ganze anleitung nochmal
zum ausdrucken und ich denke das ist
hier noch ganz schön machen ein foto für
facebook und für instagram und wir sehen
uns dann beim nächsten mal wieder bis
walter schneck so viel geredet
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich den ihnen quadratische
stücke schneiden oder in rechtecke ich
im prinzip egal und trocknen lassen ist
das habe ich das jetzt gebracht